>>> RIGHT NOW, MORE THAN 25
STATES ARE UNDER WINTER WEATHER
AND WINDCHILL ALERTS
THIS WEEK, EVERY SINGLE LOWER 48
STATES IS EXPECTED TO REACH
TEMPERATURES BELOW FREEZING.
IN CITIES SUCH AS SEATTLE, THE
FIRST SNOW HAS ALREADY FALLEN.
A MAJOR CONCERN FOR AMERICANS IS
WILL THE WEATHER AFFECT HOLIDAY
TRAVEL PLANS?
IT'S AN UNDERSTANDABLE CONCERN.
WE ALREADY HAVE LONG LINES AT
AIRPORTS.
OUR REPORTERS ARE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
L
LUCY KAVANOV IS IN DENVER.
MAN, IF DENVER WILL HAVE ONE OF
THE COLDEST DAYS IN YEARS, IT'S
GOT TO BE COLD AIR.
>> Reporter: IT DOES THAT FIELD
LIKE IT RIGHT NOW.
WE EXPECT TEMPERATURES TODAY TO
REACH AS HIGH AS 50 DEGREES, BUT
IT'S GOING TO DROP DRAMATICALLY
THIS EVENING WHEN A MAJOR STORM
BRINGS WHAT THE NATIONAL WEATHER
SERVICE BRINGS AS LIFE EMPHASIZE
THREATENING COD TO THE FRONT
RANGE.
DENVER IS EXPECTING THE THE DEEP
FREEZE EXPECTED TO LAST THROUGH
FRIDAY MORNING.
THE FORECAST, JIM, DON'T
NECESSARILY REFLECT HOW COLD
IT'S GOING TO FEEL.
WIND GUSTS AND SNOW.
IN SOME PARTS OF THE PLAINS, THE
WITCH WILL BE AS LOW AS MINUS 60
DEGREES.
FROSTBITE COULD BE CAUSED WITHIN
MINUTES.
FOLKS ARE BEING WARNED TO STAY
INDOORS.
THE GOVERNOR HAS ACTIVATED 100
NATIONAL GUARD MEMBERS TO HELP
WITH EXTREME COLD PREP RISE.
THE COLISEUM BEHIND ME WILL BE
USED AS A 24-HOUR WARMING
SHELTER.
DENVER ALSO COINCIDENTALLY UNDER
A STATE OF EMERGENCY DUE TO THE
UNEXPECTED INFLUX OF MIGRANT, SO
SOME OF THE FAMILIES WILL BE
BUSSED HERE TO THE COLISEUM TO
HAVE A WARM PLACE TO STAY.
AGAIN, TOMORROW WILL BE THE MOST
DANGEROUS DAY.
WE ARE EXPECTING THE
TEMPERATURES TO INCREASE IN TIME
FOR INCREASE, BUT AGAIN, THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED AND EXTREMELY
COLD, JIM.
UNDERSTOOD.
OMAR JIMENEZ IS AT CHICAGO'S
O'HARE AIRPORT.
YOU'RE NOT SEEING MUCH DELAYS
YET, BUT ARE AIRLINES THINKING
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF TIME?
>> Reporter: IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF TIME BEFORE WE SEE THE MASS
IMPACT ON DELAYS.
ON SOME OF THOSE FLIGHT, WE TOOK
AT SOME OF THE FLIGHTAWARE MAP,
AND O'HARE IS LEADING THE
COUNTRY IN DELAYS.
SO SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
CANCELLATIONS AT THIS PINT,
WHICH IS WHAT MOST PEOPLE WOULD
BE CONCERNED ABOUT HEADING INTO
THE HOLIDAYS.
WHILE IT'S ABOUT 10 DEGREES
OUTSIDE, IT FEELS EVEN COLDER,
IT'S REALLY TOMORROW AND INTO
THE WEEKEND WHERE THE
COMBINATION OF SNOW, WE SAID
GUSTS UP TO 50 MILES PER HOUR,
AND TERMS DROPPING AS LONG AS
NEGATIVE 30 WITH WINDCHILL.
THAT COMBINATION IS WHAT PEOPLE
FEAR WITH PEOPLE TRYING TO FLY
OR GET ON THE ROAD.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO KNOW OR
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS COMING, AND
THEY ADJUSTED.
>> THE NATIVE CHICAGOAN KNOWS I
HAVE THREE TERRIBLE MONTHS A
YEAR, AND WE'RE COMING INTO THEM
NOW.
>> WE WERE PLANNING TO TRAVEL ON
SATURDAY.
WHEN WE SAW THE STORM GROWING,
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE BETTER TO
LEAVE BEFORE THE STORM HITS.
SO WE GOT ONLINE TO SEE IF WE
COULD MAKE IT WORK ON MONDAY,
AND WE DID.
>> Reporter: YEAH, AS THE FIRST
ONE TALKED ABOUT, IT IS CHICAGO.
A LOT OF THESE PLACES CAN DEAL
WITH SNOW AND EXTREME COOLED,
BUT, AGAIN, IT'S THE COMING
TOGETHER OF ALL OF THOSE FACTORS
AHEAD OF WHAT IS TYPICALLY AMONG
THE BUSIEST TRAVEL PERIODS OF
THE YEAR.
AAA EXPECTING IT TO BE THE THIRD
BUSIEST SINCE 2000.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WANTING
TO GET PLACES, BUT WITH THE
WEATHER IT COULD MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO DO SO, AND IN THOSE
FACTORS LIE THE DANGERS.
>> THANK YOU, OMAR.
>>> JENNIFER GRAY IS AT THE
WEATHER CENTER.
WHO EXACTLY WILL BE AFFECTED, OR
MAYBE WE SHOULD SAY WHO WILL NOT
BE AFFECTED.
>> Reporter: IT'S EASY TO COUNT
THE STATES THAT ARE NOT INCLUDED
IN THE ALERTS.
IT'S GOING TO AFFECT A LARGE
CHUNK OF THE COUNTRY.
ALL THE LOWER 48 STATES WILL BE
BELOW FREEZING AT SOME POINT,
BUT THE MIDWEST WILL BE HIT THE
HAR
HARDEST, AS WELL AS THE NORTHERN
PLAINS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A FOOT OF
SNOW DEVELOPING ACROSS PORTIONS
OF THE MIDWEST.
MICHIGAN TO PICK UP A FOOT TO A
FOOT AND A HALF OF SNOW.
WE'LL SEE BLIZZARD CONDITIONS
FROM WEREN'T MINNESOTA, POSSIBLY
INCLUDING PLACES LIE CHALK, A
VERY GOOD IDEA TO CHANGE YOUR
TRAVEL.
CHICAGO WILL SEE MAJOR DELAYS
TOMORROW, AND THEN THAT WOULD
HAVE A TRICKLE EFFECT ACROSS THE
EASTERN SEABOARD.
ALSO SEE SOME VERY HEAVY
RAINFALL THERE.
THE I-95 CORRIDOR WILL BE ALL
RAY.
IF YOU ESCAPE THE SNOW, YOU WILL
NOT ESCAPE THE COLD.
THE WINDCHILLS DOWN TO 32 BELOW
ZERO IN KASPER, SOME AS LOW AS
65 TO 60 DEGREES BELOW ZERO,
EVEN AS FAR SOUTH AS TEXAS WE
WILL BE TEMPERATURES BELOW
FREEZING.
THIS IS THE HOURS BELOW
JACKSON, MISSISSIPPI COULD SPENT
80 BELOW FREEZING.
IN HOUSTON 46.
WE COULD SEE PIPES BURST ACROSS
THE SOUTH.
47 TO 14 BELOW ZERO JUST BETWEEN
THIS AFTERNOON AND TOMORROW
MORNING IN DENVER.